pour pallier un phénomène migratoire
croissant sur son territoire la lituanie
décide de construire un mur bord de ses
frontières
membre de l'union européenne et de
l'otan l'état lituanien a d'ores et déjà
installé des barbelés dans le but de
dissuader les migrants pour la plupart
originaires du moyen orient et d'afrique
mais la lituanie ne compte pas en rester
là
la première étape est une clôture en fil
de fer barbelé
dans un deuxième temps nous allons
construire une clôture physique longue
d'environ 550 km seulement le futur mur
long de 5,150 km longera la frontière
avec le territoire biélorusse alors que
les tensions entre les deux capitales
minsk et vilnius ne sont pas retombée
depuis l'élection présidentielle de 2020
en biélorussie
la lituanie qui a soutenu et donnait
refuge à des personnalités de
l'opposition biélorusse accuse son
voisin d'organiser les passages
frontaliers avec les migrants millions
européenne a décidé d'appliquer les
sanctions gouvernement biélorusse après
le déroutage d'un avion à bord duquel se
trouvait un opposant arrêté à l'aéroport
de minsk et pour la biélorussie ces
sanctions vont rentrer un impact négatif
sur la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine dans cette région ils
suspendent le financement nos différents
projets mutuellement avantageux en
biélorussie s'ils imposent des sanctions
contre la biélorussie il ne faut pas
qu'il se fâche à cause d'eux à cause
d'un afflux de migrants à cause du fait
que les migrants fuient vers leur pays
parce que les fonds qui ont été alloués
à la sécurité renforcée des frontières
auparavant seront réaffectés aux besoins
des gens ordinaires
personne ne va protéger l'occident
contre d'éventuelles détresse à ses
frais
la lituanie pays de 2,8 millions
d'habitants ont fait face à la
difficulté de loger ces nouveaux
arrivants estimé à 1500 depuis le début
de l'année contre seulement 80 en
migrant l'année dernière malgré le rejet
de toutes leurs demandes d'asile
la lituanie n'aura pour le moment
expulsé aucun migrant arrivant sur son
sol